Guys know that Linus Ulmark
now has more goals this season than 5 notable Nhlrs.
Here's a list of them.
For this list,
players have to have at least 25 games under their belt.
Jonathan June has 18 apples
through 36 games this season,
but no goals.
Guys a straight playmaker.
Ryan Reeves isn't a goal scorer or playmaker,
but he's probably the best fighter in the league.
He's got 6 assists through 52 games.
Chris Weiman had 4 goals and 20
Seven Points last season.
He has just 4 assists through 32 this year.
Troy Stetcher isn't exactly the most offensive either,
but he does have 59 games under his belt this year
and just 6 assists to show for them.
And finally,
a former Winnipeg Jet,
Brenda Lemieux is more of an enforcer.
But no goals to 27 games.
Just 3 apples.
There you have it folks.
Take a bow, Linus.